I started painting music just because I
would try to explain synesthesia so many
times it never quite made as much sense
to describe it verbally so I thought it
would be best just to put it on canvas
just because I've always been an artist
and it made it much easier for people to
be able to understand it my name is
Willis McCracken and I am a synesthetic
artist synesthesia is a neurological
condition where your brain is basically
cross-wired so certain stimuli will come
in and it'll create the wrong response
in my brain so from me that's listening
to music and it's translated into color
in my head
I'm going to paint superstition by
Stevie Wonder I love the song
superstition just because it's dynamic
and funky and just fun and expressive
whenever I start a piece if I have to
listen to the song first to even know
what kind of colors I'd like to use
there are some songs that I hate that I
like the way that they look a little bit
like a lot of pop music it can be pink
and purple and you know just all these
fun bright colors but songs not that
good
so one of the other I appreciate it
somehow you know you kind of really have
to be in the right vibe to be able to
paint if you're not in the right vibe
you're not gonna make anything good I
think the prettiest onra of music is
jazz music I love blues and golds and
whites and it just seems very pearly and
iridescent a little bit when I listen to
Etta James at last the thing that stuck
out most to me was just her voice at the
very beginning when she goes into the
last
then it's just a very bright and but
also warm sort of feeling and very kind
of classic jazzy which jazz music
generally has a very gold and blue sort
of look to it
music has always been a very big part of
my life and my older brother is very
musical
and when I think back of him playing the
guitar for me I think of the colors of
what those memories are I was always a
little disappointed because I was never
very musically inclined it was really
cool to have a way to bring music and to
you know my life in a different sort of
way
[Music]
now remember my first experience of
seeing this amazing production of art
that was different than what I had seen
and there was such a personal expression
by the person making it they may or may
not have had language they may or may
not been able to communicate with me but
they're making this work that's really
you know a window into their soul when
you ask someone who's been
disenfranchised their entire life to
tell me your story it's amazing how the
door opens
[Music]
creative growth art center is the oldest
and largest Center for artists with
disabilities in the world we were
founded the idea of disability then was
so radically different than what it is
now we didn't come out of a hospital
setting no we didn't come out of a
vocational training program we came out
of some artists getting together in a
home in Oakland putting paint on the
table in the garage and just saying this
is what artists do and this is how we
can change the social fabric from those
kind of humble beginnings we now serve a
hundred and sixty two artists with
disabilities in our studio every week
it's a very big space within that you'll
find almost every possible expression of
visual art you'll see the rug making
area in the woodshop the ceramic studio
the fashion area the painting and
drawing area and everyone's working
together and everyone can see each other
it's different than most places and some
people don't believe it some people
think like you must have doctors and you
must have all these other things so how
do you deal with the the studio every
day it's like no you know art is the
common language and a lot of our folks
don't verbalize or speak or they speak
sign language but art is the language
that moves us forward
this is called the oil red cheat number
one red is the only color I can see you
look at work of an artist like Danny
Miller you know he's pretty much
nonverbal his mother tried to encourage
him to speak by telling him how to spell
words when he was a boy every night and
he never spoke them until he started to
draw them look at an artist like Monica
Valentine she takes pins and she takes
sequins and colored beads and she
strings those together on the pin and
she puts them into styrofoam forms to
form these optically charged sculptures
when you realize that Monica has trust
etic eyes and can't see color or see
anything it moves into this whole other
range we want the voice we wanna is pure
and personalized as it can be and 45
years later it continues to work how's
that building come along Pete it's
looking good
the record of success that creative
growth has is phenomenal it's off the
charts in terms of what an art school or
any other sort of enterprise would
consider to be acceptable we have three
artists with work in the Museum of
Modern Art permanent collection in New
York in the San Francisco Museum of
Modern Art collection and this year we
have the first two people with
developmental disabilities they've work
in the Venice Biennale the Venice
Biennale is the most important
prestigious by invitation-only
exhibition in the world their work is
sought after you know a piece is done
and there's a waiting list
Rosina I haven't even said hello to you
yet today how are you to be able to work
in a place like this is beyond anything
I had hoped for I get to work with
phenomenally talented people and and to
see how they negotiate the day every day
how they get around obstacles how they
continue to say yes when everyone is
telling them no that's an amazing thing
that's a life lesson I get reminded of
every single day
[Music]
these paintings they aren't done with
acrylic oil or watercolor
it's good did you know [ __ ] Tomas
Microsoft Excel the computer program
this is a story about tats well the
Microsoft Excel artist
[Music]
what does she wanna put each tattooing
no not even an outside this when tats
will retired he decided he wanted to
paint but there was one problem he was
cheap husband cocking on a ship were
chosen to get Easter Bunny pass uncle
day
no sorry I'll get the rope in the mukou
gonna mean he wasn't named mrs. Dooley
somebody was in it he didn't even want
to pay for an art program so he used
what was already on his computer
the soyil day Gina Carano exhibit
ya see pretty cousin
so how do you paint in Excel the line
tool it's usually used for spreadsheet
graphs that you can make trees with and
the bucket tool it helps with subtle
shading on for example the crest of a
volcano
the Sioux equal 20 unit that you know MA
so that sort of a hawk in the you al can
take a Muslim votaciones saved a
Yokohama Tony Tony sending kernels Volta
Teton Sioux June and conventional
caçapava so simple rocket
yeah cream at an encode a toasty at
entire package anakov boffin and a in
Okanagan accepted in the Excel selection
[Music]
it's a you know
Nagaraja 399 oh she were very missing
today
what does he know when they put a hot
tip reverse time today baby to see you
got time disking
[Music]
the idea came from my father he told me
that there are pictures on the walls and
the subway stations of old buildings old
New York
20 years later after going through
everything school college and all that
stuff I thought I've been fine and give
it a look and just see what my father
was talking about
it was going to be a short article as an
illustration station with some pictures
and tells stories
but it kind of ran away with me
what I set out to do is make a record of
the appearance of the subway stations in
New York City
I take drawings of the mosaic or fans
designs on the walls which embellish the
station
I devoted much of my time as I can to
doing it evenings weekends vacation time
even you know it's all it's a sort of a
consuming project so far I've completed
four volumes I'm one two three and four
my ambition is to take care of all the
lines until all four hundred and ninety
four hundred ninety six hundred sixty
nine
ordering seventy stations have been
recorded and soon
[Music]
why am i doing it okay
my purpose in doing this study is to
make a record of what we've got I want
to like document when it was done and
who did it so that's what I wanted to do
that's my focus is to give credit to
those who made it possible
I really started in earnest in 1978 and
I thought I'd get this project finished
ooh wrapped up by the year 2030 which is
only fourteen years from now perhaps I
have a theory estimate and suggest maybe
close to the 2040
I mean you know 90s then but I can still
see
[Music]
pleasure doing the job is his payment
I've committed to it that's all it's my
prayer is my purpose it's my life it's
become my identity so I'd look up to it
[Music]